[Música]
y
después de cinco meses y más de 150 días
termina el aislamiento obligatorio en
colombia y empieza el aislamiento
selectivo una fase que está prevista que
dure hasta el 30 de septiembre en este
periodo de tiempo se mantienen medidas
como el uso obligatoria la mascarilla
así como la prohibición de eventos que
supongan aglomeraciones en competiciones
deportivas conciertos o discotecas por
otro lado destaca el regreso de las
reuniones así como la vuelta de los
viajes por carretera de los vuelos
nacionales y los internacionales aunque
estos últimos todavía no tienen fecha
definitiva de regreso esta reapertura
dependerá siempre del avance de la
pandemia y también de lo que decidan los
municipios con más afectación cabe
destacar que bogotá la capital pasó en
cuestión de días de una cuarentena
estricta a esta reapertura una decisión
que muchos consideran una consecuencia
de la presión social vivida las últimas
semanas por distintos sectores tras
meses de parón económico
[Música]
después de más de cinco meses de
cuarentena bolivia ha decidido abrir su
economía a partir de este primero de
septiembre y lo ha hecho en medio de una
fuerte polémica pues los médicos y otros
sectores de salud han calificado la
decisión de política y electoral de
parte del gobierno de jeanine áñez pues
si bien la curva de contagios ya se
encuentra en descenso es todavía alta en
líneas generales las actividades se
normalizan hasta las 8 de la noche de
lunes a viernes y hasta las 4 de la
tarde los fines de semana por otro lado
ya se permiten los vuelos nacionales e
internacionales y las fronteras
terrestres se mantienen cerradas en
cambio hay ciudades que han decidido
mantener las restricciones por su alto
nivel de contagios de kobe 19 como es el
caso de la paz donde todavía está
prohibida la circulación los fines de
semana también estamos impedidos los
ciudadanos bolivianos de realizar
actividades públicas culturales y
masivas hasta el momento el país
presenta más de 116 mil casos de kobe 19
y más de 5000 muertos aunque existe
coincidencia de que hay un alto
registro en el país
[Música]
gracias de desconfía miento gradual del
país en las últimas horas nueve barrios
de la región metropolitana de santiago
han avanzado a la segunda etapa de
preparación en la que la cuarentena se
mantiene únicamente los fines de semana
y con estos son prácticamente cuatro
millones de santiaguinos los que ya se
encuentran desconfiados en las próximas
horas cuatro de los barrios más
importantes de la capital pasarán al
siguiente a la siguiente etapa junto a
una comuna de la región metropolitana y
dos de la región de valparaíso se trata
del paso 3 de los 5 diseñados por el
gobierno la etapa de transición en las
que las personas pueden circular
libremente de lunes a domingo reunirse
en grupos de hasta 50 personas y también
como medida excepcional se permitirá la
apertura de restaurantes en terrazas y
veredas esta medida no estaba planteada
inicialmente en el plan del gobierno
pero se toma un ante la presión del
gremio que pide al ejecutivo mayores
ayudas rebajas de impuestos al haberse
visto fuertemente afectada por los
estragos económicos que deja tras de sí
la pandemia
[Música]